cruella de vil gets a fashionable
transformation in disney's latest
live-action reimagining of one of its
most iconic villains
yupikai movie lovers i'm jan and today
i'm explaining the biggest changes
disney made in cruella and how the new
film compares to both the animated and
live action 101 dalmatians movies
some spoilers for the new film ahead so
take care i'm just getting started
darling because this is an origin story
there's much more to the character of
cruella than we see in the 101
dalmatians movies where she arrives as
an already fully formed villain
owning every scene she's in with
extravagantly theatrical flair
in fact as much as i love dogs glenn
close hamming it up deliciously in the
remake is the only thing that made it
worth watching for me
as cruella gets the full spotlight this
time around rather than the dalmatians
her personality and background is
suitably fleshed out with nice nods to
the original films via backstories for
her name
style crazy driving henchmen and more
in a 180 degree turn from her previous
incarnations though
this cruella who starts life known as
estella even
likes canines not as future fair coats
but as
actual much-loved animal companions
cruella
is still all about the drama though
darling and emma stone does a striking
job turning her dramatic af dial up to
11.
dear the light
a brand new character we meet that's
central to estella's journey to becoming
cruella is baroness von hellman who's
head of her own
highly successful fashion house the
baroness is essentially what you get if
you took the o.g cruella de vil from 101
dalmatians and miranda priestley from a
devil where's prada
and rolled them into one and emma
thompson plays her to quietly savage
perfection
you're sweating and i can smell you when
she's not taking credit for everyone
else's work
here's to me the baroness is busy
showing her us a contempt for the rest
of humanity
that's marvelous but this narcissist who
treats pretty much everyone like dogs
stella come has got skeletons as well as
couture in her closet
and as characters that represent a clash
between the old fashioned establishment
and the cutting-edge future thompson and
stone play off each other to truly
wicked effect
1965 collection oh no wonder i love it
it's mine
i fixed it the three dalmatians owned by
the baroness in this movie are a world
away from the sweet and friendly ones in
both the 1961 and 1996 films
as the baroness herself says they're
gorgeous and vicious
it's my favorite combination and oh boy
she's not kidding
it's hardly surprising these dogs act so
vicious though
after all they do belong to the baroness
and she's viciousness personified
the dalmatians appear in several crucial
scenes that point at why corella feels
the way she does about the breed in the
original films
but unlike those movies this isn't their
story so expect to see
less of them here however cruella and
friends both have their own adorably
scrappy pooches buddy and wink that join
them on their adventures so there's
still plenty of canine shenanigans to
enjoy throughout the story
in a change from the animation but just
like the live-action remake there's no
talking animals here and the animals you
do see on screen are a mix of real-life
pups and cgi
which is similar to the 90s film though
that movie also used puppets in a few
scenes
in contrast to the 60s animation and 90s
flick which were both set around the
time they were made
cruella's new origin story issues a
contemporary setting
opting instead for the 1970s which is
the perfect backdrop for her
anarchic attitude the culture clash of
that particular period plays out
beautifully in the contrasting styles of
the baroness and cruella
the baroness has shades of establishment
fashion houses like dior about her
versus cruella's more punk sensibilities
of vivian westwood
but this isn't the first time corella's
worked in the realm of high fashion
as she ran her own company house of
deville in the 90s
her ott personal style which was mostly
two-toned with some flamboyant splashes
of colour
certainly stood out in that movie and
fit her big personality
building as it did on the iconic look in
the animation
however this latest film's fashion-led
storyline takes things to a whole new
level
giving us an outrageously tailored world
where emma stone has
47 wildly inventive costume changes
emma thompson and elegantly luxurious 33
with joel fry and pool walter hauser
getting 30 changes each too
it certainly looks like costume designer
jenny bevin will be back at the oscars
accepting another little gold statue as
she did most recently for mad max fury
road
because this stunning display of costume
design from her and her team is
definitely going to take some topping
by the way curiously the new film's
timeline where corella's in her 20s and
the 1970s
seems to fit with the timeline of the
first live-action film where glenn close
was in her 40s
on top of giving us cruella's backstory
the new movie also provides an origin
for her henchmen
jasper and horace in this version they
first meet as kids on the streets of
london and grow up grifting together so
they're basically cruella's family and
look out for one another
rather than just being the hired heavies
we know in the other films
in fact for director craig gillespie
jasper is the heart of the film the
touchstone for kerala as he tries to
stop her going too far down the wrong
path
but as cruella indulges her wicked side
more and more her
relationship with her chosen family
becomes strained is it so hard to back
me up
not estella that's easy but to help
cruella it's a nightmare
joel fry and paul walter hauser work
well together in the roles and while
fry's jasper is the one with insight
here
she has no family that's a change from
the animation where horus was the one
who generally understood what was going
on
what if they went down the frozeup creek
so as not to leave their tracks
you idiot dogs ain't that smart
interestingly houser who plays horus has
compared the characters to bert and
ernie and told comicbook.com that he
pinched bob hoskins voice from the movie
hook for the part
how can you not love this face as for
the 90s take on jasper and horus well
that
really lays the slapstick on thick
turning the purr into knock-offs of the
home alone baddies which makes sense
when you realise it was written by john
hughes who also wrote home alone
while the latest movie does follow the
original book and animation by making
anita and cruella former school friends
it breaks away from the 1996 film where
anita worked as a designer for cruella
and instead makes her a photojournalist
given how good actress kirby hal
baptiste has been in other shows she
never gets much to do
here which is a real shame looking back
there was little of interest in the
character of anita in either of the
earlier films but that was more
understandable in the animation given
its short run time and the fact the
dalmatians not
the humans were the stars when it came
to the first live action though they
somehow managed to make anita even more
bland than the animation
giving her a stereotypical 50s housewife
vibe despite the film being set in the
mid 90s
this time around roger who's played by
cave and novak
only has a small role as well he's the
baroness's lawyer and also plays piano
in a dingy little bar in a nod to the
animation where he's a songwriter and
with his wife anita
owner of the titular dalmatians as for
the 90s film where he was an american
video game designer
roger was pretty dull and actor jeff
daniels and on-screen wife jolie
richardson had almost no chemistry
in the news story roger and anita never
meet but stick around for the
mid-credits scene
as it features some easter eggs and
hints at their future together
a couple of other new characters added
to the mix are mark strong's john the
valet
an arty played by john mccree as a close
confidant to the baroness
jon knows many of her secrets and her
search plays a small but significant
role in the story
as for arty he's the lgbtq plus owner of
a vintage clothes boutique and helps
corella in her insane fashion stunts to
steal the baroness's thunder
and according to the channel mama's
geeky director craig gillespie loved
mccree's witty performance so much they
ended up adding an extra scene for him
so what do you think of disney's new
cruella do you like the changes to her
and the other characters from 101
dalmatians let me know your thoughts and
theories in the comments below
if you enjoyed this then hit that like
button and tap left for my next disney
video or tap right for something else
you're sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippee kai movie lovers